what we were taught in school about the
human migration process into North
America has been definitively debunked
in fact our textbooks currently state
the humans cross the frozen land bridge
from Russia just shy of 15,000 years ago
however the evidence I'm about to share
with you in this presentation
conclusively debunked that now it was
recently announced that Mastodon bones
found in San Diego California
dating back 130,000 years so definitive
evidence of human toolmarks now let me
first address the issue of dating how do
they know it's 130,000 years old while
utilizing advanced methods of dating
they've been able to measure the amount
of uranium deployment and decay within
these bones that turn into thorium and
what's surprising is that throughout
mainstream science they agree that yes
ok these bones are in fact 130,000 years
old which of course I was thrilled to
hear because usually I disagree with
much of what mainstream science has to
say when it comes to the age of ancient
human civilization and other things so
it's very interesting to see that there
is a consensus on that yes these bones
are 130,000 years old now what makes
this site even more interesting is that
they found seven rounded stone hammers
that have also been known to have been
used to break up bones and Willey
mammoths and mastodons by early hunters
and gatherers in North America now when
these methods have been tested by
researchers and paleontologists they
have utilized fresh remains of elephant
femurs and other various bones and
elephants and broken them up with the
various stone hammers found at these
other sites and they have found
consistencies among these seven stone
hammers found at the mastodon site and
that they have scratch marks on them
completely consistent with the other
scratch marks they have found on their
own tests by utilizing stone hammers
furthermore they also identified that
the stone hammers that cause fractures
and splintering of the various bones and
mastodons woolly mammoths and elephants
are completely identical to one another
in fact many people were involved in
this study and have completely agreed
that yes these are actual definitive
marks of human tooling now the big
obstacle now among mainstream scientists
is that they say well hold on maybe this
wasn't humans maybe this was you know
Neanderthals or something else which I
find to be incredibly hypocritical
considering the lack of evidence of that
I mean they're just suggesting something
that they don't have any proof of and
you know all the things I've researched
it seems to me that mainstream science
completely shuns arguments and involved
speculation right so they agree that the
skeleton remains with this Mastodon is
130,000 years old the agree that has
definitive evidence of human tooling
that far exceeds the possibility of just
being crushed under natural
circumstances yet although some
mainstream scientists are convinced that
this is evidence of human tooling some
will argue that well there's not enough
evidence yet to suggest that humans were
actually in North America 130,000 years
ago however they seem to be completely
ignoring all the recent evidence has
accumulated in recent years involving
connections between ancient Egyptians
and the Incans in South America as well
as connections in North America as well
for example are you aware that they have
found Aboriginal DNA from Australia in
mummies in South America this is
something that has just come out in last
year from studies that were done by
Harvard Medical School but to make
things even more confusing they have
found ancient remains in North American
Indians that have middle-eastern DNA
that's pretty incredible and the
evidence goes even further than that
they have actually found traces of
nicotine and cocaine in mummies found in
ancient Egypt which is completely
unexplainable considering that cocaine
and nicotine originates from plans from
Mesoamerica and South America how in the
world did ancient Egyptians have this in
their bloodstream then but it doesn't
even end there in fact let me show you
some slides that I've had in other
videos related to this topic of the
connections between the ancients among
various continents around the world
whether it's the incredible similarities
between pyramids found in South America
Central America Egypt Asia or whether it
comes from the incredible similarities
between the stone cuttings found in
Egypt Italy Turkey Peru or even the use
of trapezoidal doors or the use of gold
funeral masks or the depiction of the
third eye or even animals depicted on
the forehead those are just a few
examples of the connections between
ancient cultures that span across
multiple continents around the world and
it's pretty incredible I mean can you
honestly say that this is all just a
coincidence
and what's the recent evidence
of 130 thousand year old Mastodon bones
with human tooling you have to start
asking some real questions now many
people will say well wait a second if
they were able to travel between the
continents where's the evidence where's
where's the boat now let me give you the
example of the Titanic and I've used
this in other presentations as well
which is that you had 50,000 tons of
steel and iron that have been under the
ocean for a hundred and five years and
more than fifty percent of it is
completely disintegrated or even if you
find you know cars or houses that are
outside untouched by humans for decades
and just left in the elements the rusul
cave in the rust inside and out and
within a matter of just a few hundred
years ll be as if they were completely
non-existent altogether so even if the
ancients had say wood boats do you
really think there would be anything
less of it after tens of thousands of
years now I do have other videos that
discuss the Cataclysm that there's
overwhelming evidence that 13,000 years
ago and eleven thousand six hundred
years ago there were two massive events
there were complete reset buttons to
human civilization definitely check
those out anyways guys it's time that we
start asking real questions about the
true history of human civilization and
if you start digging into this subject
you will see that we are far older and
far more advanced than we were ever
taught in school anyways guys I'll leave
it at that
I'm Jimmy this is bright insight like
and subscribe and leave me a comment let
me know what your thoughts are and I
have many more videos to come and a
whole wide variety of topics take care
everybody